we want to study practical chess and
games that are going to really help us
in our practice and I as a reminder
would like to again tell you about rook
endings rook endings are by far the most
frequently occurring chess endings of
course you'll have Queen endings of
course you'll have King and pawn n games
you'll have minor piece end games but
the rook endings tend to be at least
half at least half of all of the major
end games that you're going to ever play
and it's really really easy to lose King
and pawn end games when you don't have
some knowledge in fact so much so that
the game that I've chosen is actually a
game that world champion Magnus Carlsen
lost in a rook ending where he was a
pawn down he was a pawn behind and um he
didn't draw a game he should have so
it's very easy to lose recompiling games
on the other hand certain rook and pawn
n games are very easy to win
so long as you know the proper technique
this comes from mussina mussina position
gosh I have it in my mind it's like 1497
so we're talking about an endgame that's
been known for 500 years the idea of
these endings is that whenever you're
upon a head as is this situation where
your King the aggressive side the pawn
with upon the side with the pawn
advantage whenever his King is on the
promotion Square it's a win
except when there are a there are pawns
on the a file and H file and we'll look
at that next but any pawn on the GF did
it too good all the way over to the B
file whenever you have a position like
this it's a win but how to win it the
direct way is if you move your king then
what happens is black just keeps giving
a series of checks and no progress is
being made
he's just giving you all of these checks
and you're right back in the place you
started then white black makes a tempo
so all of those moves and now you've got
to be careful that you don't fall into a
three move repetition as you've allowed
all kinds of checks so how on earth can
you win this game how can you win this
position and the basic idea is that
you're going to have to move your King
either to the C file or to the a file
and to block your opponent from giving
you a check yeah so the winning move if
you're not familiar is a little bit
strange the winning move is to come up
with the rook rook to d4
now basically black cannot move he has
to wait and we'll try to understand what
White's idea is let's say white black
pardon me waits by tempo in with his
rook now we're ready king c7 and we're
threatening now to make a queen black
has no choice but to give a check once
more we are threatening to make a queen
black has no choice but to give a check
and now we wait
king c6 now in this exact moment white
is not
threatening to queen so because you will
take the new queen so black has a move
so to speak it is blacks turn to play
and he can make a move let's say he
waits now white plays rook
oops scuse me rook to d5 and now what
White's idea is he's going to block with
his rook and so it's a very easy win now
check and suddenly there's no more
checks along the B file and we win let's
go back a few moves to this position and
we didn't last time we made a waiting
move if we make a check King comes to be
g2 b5 check rook and again this is a
winning idea okay let's go back to this
position and let's imagine that black
had waited with King here now how can
white win
that's a question for yourself how
should white win this position in men
you
wait to move wait to play and win white
play
not so sure okay whenever you get into
these K king and rook and pawn versus
King rook one of the things you should
always be trying to do is push the
defenders king away obviously the two
kings are in opposition so it's always a
very very good idea to give check let's
imagine we give a check if blacks King
allows White's rook to come down then
white is threatening to promote the pawn
to a queen and to capture with the rook
and now rook checks are ineffective the
King just come walks up this way all the
way back to the rook and white wins back
here a moment if black plays the move
King back to f7 protecting the square e
eight now you play rook here and once
again all you're trying to do is bring
your rook across so that you can promote
the pawn okay oops excuse me so this is
a win Mike did you have a question what
just in a bad position how about right
here for white yes right right god I
hope to see four in this position
yes run by King disease if you could get
rook to c4 and King to c7 that would be
an easy win but he'll stop you with King
back to thee that would indeed that
would be a very easy win because you've
stopped the rook from checking so that
would be a very nice one here so uh oops
I should hit okay you can see
right this is not the Lucina positions
so whenever you have a b c d e f g pawn
with a king in front it's always a win
it's always a win the a pawn as well as
the H pawn require that the defenders
King be four files away from the
promoting pawn
how can white win this position how can
white win this position
yes Ingrid
sorry
rook d4 oh yeah rook efore pardon me
sorry rook efore okay and then we wait
and king b7 and now because you're
threatening to make a queen I have to
give you a check King a6
and now once again because you're
threatening to make a queen I'll give
you a check and now I don't want to give
you another check because I see your
clever play your idea is if I give you a
check you move King here check and block
huh
so you'll you reach this position and
I'll wait I'll make a tempo
yes and that's the point rook e8 and you
get that same position like we had a
moment ago where all of these checks
basically just bring the white King and
eventually you get to a position where
you'll be able to promote your pawn to a
queen yes
right so one of the things that you can
do is play rook over rook to be won and
in case the King comes over you can put
your king in importantly and I don't
have this checking and checking device
yes so you only have this possibility of
winning it if for example this would be
really really terrible when the
defenders King excuse me
when the defenders King is this close he
traps the opponent's king in the corner
and so you cannot get out so that's why
you need these files for example King
check King and you're not making any
progress so in this position what we
discover is that this King is simply too
close and it controls too many squares
so there has to be a distance when you
have the eight or H pawns did I and you
did the lights for file yeah I think I
think I had it right here
so one I'm sorry maybe I'm counting it
wrong one two three four five yes
this is five miles high right yes this
is five house so the king it was a four
I'll closer and you still do that
let me check that let's see let's say in
this position we wait and we go here we
go here and now let's say I go here so
yes this position I'm seeing this is a
win so I wanted to send fragments but
somehow sending them to Ben's computer
didn't seem to work the next position
and this is a very vital one this
position is known as the Philidor
position essentially a moment ago if we
could put if if we could trade King pip
places and put this White King in front
of the pawn and this King off of the
promotion Square white wins it's a
simple easy win as we've seen building a
bridge in this position it's a kind of a
tzuke's wong mutual zooks well the idea
is if it's white to move white wins if
it's black to move black draws okay
the Philidor defense is very very simple
a black to move draws what black should
do is step back with his rook along the
sixth rank if it was the colors were
reversed it would be the third rank what
black the defender needs to do is he
needs to get white to push his pawn as
soon as white pushes his pawn to e6 the
rook comes down and checks us from
behind so let's say that it's black to
black to play and black does not know
the Philidor defense instead black
errors oh I've got to make it black to
move sorry black errors with this very
bad move the King comes up and now white
is threatening to play check
and and force the king out of the way of
the pond
now after check the King comes here and
we're threatening a mate well or at
least let's say a very important check
the black king is forced to give up the
defense and now white will simply
advance his pawn all the way up he'll
advance his pawn then his King then his
pawn and he'll get a winning position
Lulu say 'no position so back to the
start and after this bad move by white
black should play this this is a crucial
move rook to g6 closing across the
third-ranked
what could white do if white moves his
rook and just plays around with his rook
black is waiting he just waits he waits
until white advances his pawn oops
have I done it wrong the moment White's
pawn goes to escape the moment White's
pawn gets to the e6 square now you drop
behind and there's no shelter for the
King if the pawn were up on e5 the e
square e six squared would be the
shelter and so now you can just forever
harass the white king check check check
eventually when the King gets too far
away from the pawn on e6 we'll just go
back and attack it and that's an easy
draw let's go back to the start and
let's see how you would win the position
if it was white turn what would you play
you have only one winning move Julian
King d6 that is the winning move
King e6 would throw away the win because
then we would be right back
in the Philidor position so king d6 and
let's see why this is the winning move
all right
so let's say I my problem is if I check
you now you're threatening me with mate
in one
yeah and if I move away with my king now
my king is no longer there the moment I
get this position it is impossible to
stop light from pushing his pond and
getting the winning position okay
so let's say in this moment I come down
oops sorry I don't give you a check I
come down right away and now how are you
going to win the position
yeah
sorry say it again please white plays
with his rook and that's correct but
where Julian rook a a Czech King has to
go here ecigs let's I go King here
kingi 7 is good you you in this
particular case you don't have to be
fancy schmancy yeah exactly
you could go to UC 7 let's say I had
gone King here rook f8 let's say I gone
King here again the funny part is in
this case you don't have to be fancy and
again and these rook checks just
basically white crawls back to the
checking rook and in the meantime you
Queen the pawn these bring practical
rook endings I cannot repeat to yourself
how many times I've had both sides I've
been a pond down made a draw without a
problem been upon up and made a win
because I knew the proper technique the
game I wanted to bring to your attention
I thought was pretty interesting game it
was a Magnus Carlsen it was a Wang Hao a
grandmaster from China and the
tournament was played in Norway at their
most prestigious chess tournament of the
year the Norway chess event in Norway
chess tournament and the players reached
the following ending Magnus Carlsen the
world champion had white pieces and this
is a very simple four versus three
ending the difference here is that
normally speaking this pawn on d5 in a
normal four versus three might be for
example on the e6 square at the moment
this pawn has passed so clearly white is
the defender and trying to keep
everything together magnus carlsen lost
this ending and this really really
shocked the chess world because magnus
is really world renowned for not only
being a great grinder himself but he's
the guy who's supposed to be winning
these endings not losing them and
especially because we thought that this
ending was it a draw
not necessarily an easy draw for white
but certainly you draw King f6 King III
King over okay
so the normal drawing technique is that
when you're the defender in such
positions you put your rook behind the
passed pawn and that's what Magnus did
and here we were all very surprised that
Magnus simply didn't keep his rook again
just behind the past pawn it makes it
very very hard for black to make
progress so the first principle is to
keep your rooks behind the past boss
don't forget that one that makes it
really easy now rook check okay so the
idea of when how was that if White's
King moved to d4 he wanted to bring his
rook to f3 and go after this pawn on f2
so Magnus played king f4 and we got here
a moment ago when white could have put
his rook behind excuse me miss again
when white could have put his rook
behind the pawn Magnus would have a
choice of whether to put his King on f3
or d3 now he really doesn't he put his
king on d3 Julian yeah yes of course so
let's go back to that moment ago so we
are here here rook here and then what
Julian asked is cannot can't couldn't
black play rook d6 basically forcing the
rook aside for a moment all right now
let's say I move a moment ago you saw
Wang Hao was checking now his rooks
behind now the question is how can you
make progress if you move your king with
something like this actually happened in
the game by the way so it's interesting
to compare in this position I want to
check you like this yeah so my king is
blockading this pawn my king is
blockading the pawn tying down the rook
and your King cannot enter me enter on
the Kings side let's see what happened
after rook be seven basically what I
wanted to say is after the check Magnus
had to play his King to d3 the problem
oops excuse me the problem if he had
played his king to f3 is nobody's really
guarding the D pawn anymore nobody's
really guarding the D pawn anymore and
after whoops
let's go rook e1 now White has to be
very careful that the pawn just doesn't
make it up the board the rook on d8 that
wouldn't be the case okay so check rook
e1 now we have a series of moves
and we're back okay so now we're back to
very very safe territory this is really
really easy draw let's say in the game
when how he's basically he's hit a
roadblock
he can't advance his King on the Kings
side he can't advance his pawn his rook
is protecting the pawn
he played back King back now in this
position I was a bit surprised well
actually more than a bit surprised by
Magnus's choice Magnus and the game he
played the move rook g7 this was played
in the game Rupe g7 would that have been
your choice
how would you if you were the defender
in this position have defended it I did
very good very good
maintain your rook behind the pawn rook
to d8 this was a very strange decision
by Magnus rook g7 forcing the opponent
to advance his pawn g5 Magnus goes rook
h7 and now we have g4 now already things
aren't getting are getting a little bit
nervous here for white in the game
Magnus took F takes G for why didn't
Magnus play F for MN
absolutely rook e1 if you wanted to play
rook f5 shame on you
look at that rook on f5 this would this
would be the rook is almost stuck
is it it would be a terrible move but
rook e1 and suddenly after rook takes h5
rook to g1 black has suddenly real
chances of winning the game because he
wants to put his rook to take this pawn
on g3 put his rook on h3 and on a very
good day be able to bring his King to
five so in the game
Magnus captured capture capture me reach
this position and it's still a draw it's
still a draw only Magnus is making it
more more difficult for himself in the
game Magnus has played rook g7 f5 rook
g6 King here and here Magnus made a very
strange move he moved his rook rook to
a6 well obviously he has a passed pawn
in the position
why didn't Magnus play h5 you know
f/4 takes
and takes easy draw easy drop that's
what magma should be trying to do h5 if
you come down like we had that previous
variation if you come down here with
rook here now I'll activate my King if
you go over I'll activate my King and if
you take I'll take this pawn and I'll
make a very easy draw with white Magnus
did not do that the world champion
played rook here and already things are
starting to get a little bit tricky
after this move rook down Magnus
played King to d2 which was a opening
yes Julian yes
rook d6 was also much much stronger I
like the move
h5 I think h5 is the simplest but
definitely rook d6 was also an excellent
choice I just didn't understand this
move rook a six at all now once again
Magnus made a very strange choice king
d2 again I don't think it's losing after
this move it only makes it White's task
that much harder normally speaking
whenever you're the defender in these
work endings it's it's really vital in
fact it's super necessary that you be as
active as possible a much stronger
decision was to play king d4 the idea of
king d4 is not only because you want to
capture this pawn on d5 but also you're
looking for opportunities of going to e5
and capturing this pawn as well as to
explain why he played this move King D
to Magnus said that he thought he had
calculated out the game and he saw that
it was a draw he saw he thought he saw
force draw so his idea was to defend
and kind of like the Philidor style
right to defend along the third-ranked
check now again White's King is now
suddenly very very passive a moment ago
it was on d4 sometimes it was going to
e5 now it's been driven all the way back
down to the first rank and we get this
position this is the position Magnus had
had foreseen he thought that his past H
pawn he was just going to run his past H
pawn up the board and he would have
everything under control
he was wrong rook H 2 H 6 D for King G 1
rook H 3 and now I think this was the
losing moment right here I think that
after the move King G 2 it's lost and
that King F 2 was just a tempo to save
the game let's see how Magnus lost it
after King G 2 interestingly in reading
the comments of both players after the
game both players thought this position
was a draw and they were just playing on
you know because the crowd people I use
upon up you and then suddenly wang hao
saw the winning variation remember those
those positions i was just showing you
you've got one only this time there's a
lot more pawns on the board okay now
before we knew how we knew how to build
a bridge when there were no pawns on the
board and the moment the rook is kind of
like offsides
but how can black build a bridge
in this position how could black build a
bridge you yeah yeah and then your look
along the third-ranked
can block a Czech f4 kingi - now you're
ready to play rook to d3 or me now
you're ready to play rook to d3 and
Queen rook to e3 also well at the moment
you're threatening to Queen
you just queen and take the rook and
that would be the end of the game so
Magnus had to give a check that answers
your question Berg either yeah yes it
would okay now let's think about this
well why can't prevent black from
Queenie but maybe white can Queen now if
we imagine push
Queen Queen this looks like a drawing
rook we nap on endgame but is it no
Magnus lost
why did Magnus lose what could why what
could black do here that gives him
victory young man cleanup 3 check
correct
black queen f1 check Bravo you guys have
gotten it you got yes
g3 check I'll sweep you have to take
with the King check and you have to go
now to the H file either to the h4
square or to the h5 Square h3 or h4
square it doesn't matter and check and
you can the Queen so very very nice
played by Wang Hao and this ending is
known for many years as a drawn ending
exactly let's go back to the disposition
where we were here so we should he
should have gone King f2 in the game
just a sec analogous notation yes King
f2 ok so the difference is not to allow
that King blacks King to come running
all the way up the board and that was a
big difference yes yeah so here so when
you guys play a rook and pawn endgame
and you know you go home and you put it
in your chess engine and chess engine
says equal equal equal and then suddenly
goes minus 10 you discovered a move that
suddenly your game is completely lost
well console yourselves it happens to
the best of the best including the world
champions and rook endings can be very
tricky the general rule of thumb is you
absolutely should put your rook behind
pawns whether you're the defender or the
aggressor you've got to know the Lucena
position you got another Philidor
position and that will help you at an
enormous degree when I study rook and
pawn end games I like to have a guide
I've always said this about an opening
if I'm going to learn an opening I want
to learn it from somebody
who's really really super professional
and knows the opening inside out I'm
going to learn a grünfeld I want Peter
Svidler to be my guide if any of you are
having trouble with rook and pound
endgames
your guide should be vasily smyslov okay
you just go to the database you get your
database and you just what you do is the
games of vasily smyslov you just click
the final position if it's a rook ending
go earlier and see how he wanted or drew
it if it's if it's over in 20 moves you
click to the next game vasily smyslov
essentially bobby fischer this is what
Bobby Fischer thought about vasily
smyslov zurich endings bobby fischer got
the original book rook endings by vasily
smyslov in russian he got the book and
took the russian english dictionary and
for every single word he translated into
english he crossed it out and he wrote
in the english word okay and he did this
for the entire book i don't want to say
he memorized the book but he believed
vasily smyslov he believed ashley smith
sloth was the best rook ending player in
the world and well if it was good enough
for bobby fisher' good enough for me
good
you